all right so our next speaker back when
she worked in animal rescue which was a
long time ago she had a Class A
commercial license and she was able to
parallel park a semi truck
I can't even imagine seeing that
everyone please welcome Jessica
I'm Jessica Duncan I'm a marketing data
scientist at Greenlight and I'm also a
teaching assistant at Northwestern in
their School of Professional studies and
their graduate data science program and
I'm really excited this is actually my
first time here at New York our
conference in person done it virtually
several times and you already saw the
spoiler I was supposed to be here last
year but I had twins and we have some
good reading material for them thank you
clearly so they're they're getting a
good start they'll pass me up soon
enough I'm sure
but we're here to talk about marketing
channel attribution and what it is and
why it's important and how we can do it
better with r
so at the base level marketing
attribution is understanding which of
your customers touch points along their
customer Journey with you are most
influential in converting them to a
purchasing customer
and touch points can be anything from
social media whether it's paid social
media or organic social media it might
be traditional media like Print TV radio
Podcast newspaper or it could be email
marketing your website a phone customer
service center if you have anything like
that touch points can also be things
that you can't necessarily track well
like Word of Mouth
um but as a marketer we want to drive
our marketing efficiency well with our
spend right we have a certain amount of
money that we get to put towards all
these channels and we want to divvy it
up in such a way that it brings us the
most customers with the fewest costs
right marketing efficiency so we need to
know how to take all of those dollars
across all of those different channels
that we might have and get the most
customers biggest bang for our buck
right
so let's walk through a hypothetical
let's say that we have a company that
sells baby shoes and I can tell you from
personal experience baby shoes are among
the cutest and least functional things
in the world but you absolutely need
them
so we sell baby shoes and we have social
media ads and we managed to get our
social media ad in front of a parent
who's scrolling Instagram maybe one day
while the kid is napping and they come
across this ad and they think oh my God
these are the cutest shoes I've ever
seen I absolutely have to have them and
they click through the ad they land on
our website and they find a handful of
shoes that they love they add them to
their cart they're almost done they
almost get through the checkout process
and then baby wakes up crying and so
parent scampers off to go do parenting
things and care for the baby and then as
a marketing team we notice hey there's a
cart that's been sitting there for a
while and nobody's finished it so let's
fire off an email and say hey did you
forget your card so we send that email
later that evening parents checking
email sees our email thinks ah the shoes
clicks through buys the shoes
everybody's happy the end right so
you've probably had an experience like
that before you've certainly seen social
media ads maybe you've interacted with
them you've probably gotten a hated you
forget your cart type of email from a
company before this is just one example
of a customer Journey right this was a
pretty simple straightforward one but
they're not always simple and they also
don't always end in a conversion
customers can have many many touch
points with your company and never
actually purchase anything or they might
come directly to you again maybe through
Word of Mouth they just go straight to
your website and buy something and they
didn't have any traditional marketing
touch points in that sense and so that's
where marketing attribution modeling
helps us to understand all of these
different things right we put all these
touch points together and all the
different combinations that they could
possibly exist and then we say which of
these is working well for us and where
should we put more of our marketing
dollars or maybe more topically the last
few years we're having our marketing
budget reduced where can we take money
away and have the least impact on our
overall sales and conversions
so let's talk about kind of how we
traditionally handle marketing
attribution first and then we'll talk
about the better way to do it so rules
based is where many marketing
departments are still sitting and single
touch is also still a very common way to
handle marketing attribution
those two are first touch and last touch
and they really are exactly what they
sound like it's giving a hundred percent
of the credit to a sale to the very
first marketing touch point that a
customer has or the very last touch
point that a customer has so in our
hypothetical situation we would either
give a hundred percent of the credit for
our sale to that Instagram ad or we
would give a hundred percent of the
credit to the sale to that marketing
forgotten cart email that we send now
you can see the problem with that of
course it's ignoring everything else
between but it's also ignoring the
relationship between those two things
our customer may never have even
remembered they were shopping for baby
shoes if we hadn't sent them that email
and we also wouldn't have had a reason
to send them the email if they'd never
seen the Instagram ad to start with so
believe it or not there's still a lot of
marketing departments that are sitting
right here using either first touch or
last touch as their way of assessing
their marketing channels there is a
better way to do it
one sort of Step Up but still not quite
there is multi-touch attribution but
still rules based and so these are still
very formulaic where we take however
many marketing touch points we have and
we say this is how we're divvying up the
credit for those touch points so one
would be linear where we give Equal
Credit to every touch point along a
customer Journey
and you could see where that potentially
would be problematic with difference in
intent right there's a difference in
customer intent from passively scrolling
just having to see one of your ads
versus getting to your website filling
out a form giving you their email
address so you can stay in touch right
those are different intents from a
customer level so you may not want to
give Equal Credit to those touch points
other multi-touch attribution
rules-based options are u-shaped and
time Decay and this is where we're sort
of trying to walk this line of we want
to give credit to more than just the
first or the last but we don't exactly
know how to do it so we're just going to
kind of throw some numbers at it right
u-shape says we're going to give a lot
of credit to the first touch and the
last touch and a little bit in between
and time Decay says we're going to give
the most credit to the most recent touch
point and then sort of stair step it
down these numbers are sort of made up
and hypothetical you could set any
percentage that you wanted and so
they're again trying to move away from
that single touch mentality but they're
still not necessarily the best way to do
it with time Decay or u-shaped for that
matter you're ignoring the difference in
length of customer Journeys right our
hypothetical our parent who was
scrolling Instagram that was maybe a
several hours long customer Journey from
first touch point to purchase your
customers may have days or weeks long
journey and so then how do we treat that
time decay of most recent versus recent
if they were a few hours apart or days
or weeks ago
so A Better Way exists and it's actually
quite easy with r there's a package that
does it for you very well
and Markov chain is the sort of math
underlying it so we'll walk through what
is a Markov chain and how do we use it
in marketing attribution
Markov chain is a way of understanding
the likelihood of moving from one state
to another state or staying in the same
state so it's a probabilistic model
we'll use another baby example let's say
these are the three states that my twins
could be in any given time they're
either smiling crying or they're asleep
and so the likelihood then of them
moving through these states maybe will
say they have a 32 percent chance of
staying happy 26 chance of starting to
cry or a 42 chance of falling asleep
you'll notice those numbers add to 100
so for each sort of spoke in the chain
we have to have a probability that adds
to one of either staying where we are or
moving somewhere else
and same for crying
either staying where we are or moving to
sleeping or happy and sleeping staying
asleep starting to cry
there we go we're starting to smile so
this is an example of a very simplified
Markov chain but in terms of marketing
attribution this would be a situation
where each of these steps would be a
marketing channel right we would say
it's a social media exposure it's a
traditional media exposure radio TV
newsprint what have you right and so the
attribution then looks at what's the
probability if somebody comes in through
social media that they're either going
to directly convert or they're going to
maybe have another touch point or
another two or three touch points before
they convert and that helps us get a
more holistic view of our marketing
program in total instead of looking at
it in a very specific rules-based chunk
so let's look at some code which is the
fun stuff as I mentioned the package
here Channel attribution which we'll
talk more about in a second really kind
of does all the work for you which is
great but you of course have to start
with data in the real world we know that
getting the data getting it clean is the
hardest part of any modeling process
right and particularly with marketing
that's become more challenging over the
last several years when we have privacy
rules from IOS and Google making it
harder to track what Impressions
somebody might have directly with us so
for example's sake we're going to have
perfectly beautiful clean data that
we're just going to create ourselves but
in the real world you of course would
want to get your data and get it as
clean as possible before you would start
this process
so this chunk of code really just
um creates some data out of thin air for
us to use we're calling our marketing
channels A B C D E and F and then we're
creating some random samples of fake
touch points with customers
so the output of this is
there we go really three channels you
have a way to identify your customer so
a customer ID for example you have a
date or a time stamp or something that
allows you to put those touch points in
order from most recent to least recent
in terms of when they happened and then
you have an identification of this is
the channel this is the touch point that
they have
now getting this in a sort of
understanding what it looks like overall
that line of code estimates roughly 6
500 customers with 50 000 touch points
over roughly six months with a typo
um
and this is an estimation of the number
of touches in each of those paths so for
our fake data most of our customers have
something like seven or eight touch
points with us before their customer
Journey ends and their customer Journey
can end in a purchase or their customer
Journey could end without a purchase it
would just stop they would have no more
marketing touch points but this is what
we're looking at some customers have a
whole lot of touch points some have very
few most have somewhere in the seven to
eight range
now getting it in the structure that the
channel attribution package uses
um is pretty simple as well it's a
relatively short piece of code that
takes
our ID date Channel data frame and puts
it into order essentially so that you
have one row per customer each touch
point is in order from the first to the
most recent and then it has a either
conversion or non-conversion so that's
what it looks like at the end you can
see the greater than symbol really is
what indicates that we're moving from
channel to channel and this is again
just the format that the channel
attribution package once so we have our
customer ID we have our
path and then we have conversion or not
conversion
this is the package that I've used again
it's very straightforward it does all
the stuff for you so it's relatively
easy for a marketer to use and I say
that as a former marketer
the great thing about it is it not only
is going to give you the Markov chain
version of Channel attribution but it's
also going to show you that first touch
and last touch and linear so you can
compare and see what the results would
be if you did it any number of ways
the code to get that is also very simple
two lines the H mod line here is what
gives you your single touch and your
multi-touch rules based version and the
M mod is what gives you the Markov chain
version of attribution each of them just
takes your data frame the column that
has your path in it the column that has
your conversion in it and this is what
it spits out
so on the left you see the first touch
last touch in Lanier attribution of each
of those channels how many sort of win a
conversion right and on the right side
you see the Markov chain
math behind it of once we put it through
that probabilistic approach then how
many conversions does each of those
channels get credit for and we can make
this prettier we can make it nicer for
our stakeholders to look at this is
using ggplot I don't have the code up
here just because it's a little longer
but it is on GitHub for anybody who is
curious so this you can see directly
compares
what our attribution is per Channel and
how it differs between the approaches so
first touch versus last touch for
instance for channel e and channel a are
quite different right they completely
flop so depending on how you're
approaching first touch or last touch in
a single touch attribution world you're
going to get very different answers for
those two channels in particular but in
this case you can see Channel a and
channel e aren't actually working maybe
as hard for us as we thought they were
when you put them through the Markov
chain and by contrast channels b c are
actually maybe working a little better
for us than we thought and so I like
this approach because it gives us I
think again a more holistic view of what
is our um
whole picture of our marketing not just
where people come from not just where
they end but what was their whole
journey throughout their process as a
customer and how much credit should we
give to each of those touch points
another output is the transition Matrix
and this tells you the probability of
moving from one channel to another
Channel throughout your process as a
customer and again we can make this
prettier because this is not easy to
look at and we only have six channels in
this example imagine if you had many
more this again is just using ggplot and
it's taking those same numbers throwing
them up here so as an example to walk
through over on the y-axis or at the
origin you see start and then as you go
across the row those are the
probabilities that a customer is going
to come into a customer Journey with us
through any of those channels so the
highest likelihood is that a customer
will enter a customer journey through
Channel B
and the lowest likelihood is that
they'll enter through Channel C and
again if you were to add all these up
you'd see each row adds to one
and then sort of following that along if
they're most likely to come in through
Channel B let's go back to the y-axis
and say well if they're starting at
Channel B then the most next likely
place for them to land is actually
Channel e the least likely place for
them to land next would be a direct
conversion so
estimating how people move throughout
their customer Journeys with you helping
you as a marketer to understand where
are people most likely to go where are
they least likely to go that process
again of I've got a certain budget and I
either need to spend it wisely ER more
wisely
in terms of I'm having a budget reduced
so I need to stop spend but lose as few
customers as possible or all of a sudden
I have more marketing money where can I
put it to gain the most
and this helps you I think to do that
better than the single touch
a couple of things to consider
we talked about data do you have the
data right we we mentioned things like
word of mouth or even newspaper right
um many moons ago when I worked in
advertising one of the things we did to
track whether someone was seeing our
newspaper ads was we had a different
phone number on every single ad we ran
so then we could track what ad that
particular person saw before they called
us with questions but do you have the
data or can you estimate it or can you
sample it
also Markov chain assumes that the
movement between and among states is
independent and that they do not
influence each other before I worked at
Greenline I worked at Boston Scientific
where I ran a model like this and one of
the sort of required steps of a customer
Journey there was to have a phone
consultation and so the first time we
did this the model essentially just said
we'll just give it everybody on the
phone because then they convert and that
might be true but you got to get their
phone number from somewhere right so we
ended up running two of these models
sort of pre-foned to understand what's
the best way to get somebody to the
phone and then after phone what's the
best way to make sure they convert which
we've talked to them and then also
thinking about timelines how long is
your customer Journey when do you
restart it if somebody began their
customer Journey with you six months ago
do you restart it at some point if
somebody purchases from you do you then
restart it or does that purchase become
another step towards their next purchase
those are all things to consider
and list of resources
packages that I used reference and I've
got three minutes left so you can get to
your coffee and stuff earlier than you
might otherwise have thank you
[Applause]